amanda lives in fairbanks alaska the
table below shows the temperature
changes in fairbanks over a two hour
period
so when we went from 3 pm to 4 pm the
temperature increased by 2 degrees
celsius and then from 4 to 5 the
temperature decreased by 5 degrees
celsius
amanda notices the temperature at 5 pm
is negative 9 degrees celsius
what was the temperature in fairbanks at
3
3pm
so they're essentially telling us the
temperature at the end of these changes
and they want us to figure out the
temperature at the beginning of these
changes so let's see if we can do that
let me draw
since in thermometers we're used to
thinking vertically so i'll draw a
vertical number line here to think about
this a little bit
so
here we go
all right so at 5 pm we end up at
negative 9 degrees celsius so let's just
say this is zero negative one two three
three
four five six
seven eight nine so we end up at
negative nine degrees celsius this is
zero degrees celsius right over here
so from zero sorry from 4 pm to 5 pm the
temperature dropped the temperature
dropped by 5 degrees celsius and that
got us to negative 9. so we dropped by
five to get to negative nine so we must
have started five above negative nine so
one two three four five
right over here
so this is that drop
this is that five degree drawing we said
one two three four five
so that's that five degree drop right
over here this is a negative five
degrees celsius
so at 4 pm
right at 4 pm
we must have had a temperature of well
five above negative nine is going to be
negative four
negative four degrees celsius this is
what the temperature was at four pm
so this is at
four
at 4 00 pm
and then
to figure out 3 p.m remember when we go
from 3 p.m to 4 p.m our temperature
increased 2 degrees celsius
so we increased by 2 degrees celsius
from that hour
to get to negative 4 degrees celsius so
we increased by 2 degrees celsius so if
we increase from 2 by 2 degrees celsius
to get to negative 4 that means at 3 pm
we must have been 2 below that so this
is what we did from three to four
from three to four we increased by two
to get to
to get to negative four
so this right over here is the plus two
degrees celsius
right over there so we must have started
right here
at 3 p.m we must have started right
there at 3 pm all i did is unwind this
if we know we're at negative 9 to end
with and from 4 to 5 5 we dropped
negative 5 to get there that means at 4
we must have been 5 above negative nine
so we were at negative four and then
from three to four if we increased two
degrees to get there that means at three
we must have been two degrees below
negative four so this right over here is
negative 6 degrees celsius so what was
the temperature at fairbanks at 3 pm it
was negative 6 degrees celsius and you
can verify that if you start at negative
6 you add 2
you get to negative 4 and then you
subtract 5 you get to negative 9 which
is exactly what we had here